I've been telling anybody that will listen
that Mitch McConnell is almost as important
as Donald Trump to remove in 2020 McConnell
is a Republican senator from Kentucky.
He's the Senate majority leader.
He has been a really effective Republican
legislator and when I say that I'm, I'm praising
him only in the fact that he's been able to
achieve so much.
Not that he's achieved anything I like.
I think his achievements have been wholly
destructive actually, but he has been effective
in a way that is extraordinarily detrimental
to the country.
And I would argue that it is nearly as important
to remove him in 2020 as it is to remove Donald
Trump.
And Mitch McConnell now has a 2010 20 challenger
who I'm going to tell you about in a second
now.
In what ways has McConnell been effective?
He's been effective, effective for a decade.
Insignificantly pushing the U s judiciary
to the right.
And this ranges from lower courts all the
way up to and including the Supreme Court.
You might remember notably at the end of Barack
Obama's presidency, um, uh, Merrick garland
was nominated by Barack Obama to the Supreme
Court and Mitch McConnell was able to successfully
stonewall that nomination, not even hold confirmation
hearings.
And that led directly to Donald Trump getting
an additional supreme court pick once he became
president and was inaugurated.
And that is a decade long.
That's a, that's a win for the right.
That will pay dividends for decades long after
Mitch McConnell was gone, uh, Mitch McConnell
has been obstructing all attempt to secure
the 2020 election from foreign interference.
Mitch just isn't gonna have it.
Okay.
And meanwhile, Mitch is taking money from
lobbyists for the biggest voting machine manufacturers
in the United States.
Now, I could go on and on, but this guy's
toxic.
He's a truly negative influence on our country,
on our society, on our culture, on our economy.
Amy McGrath is a retired fighter pilot, a
Democrat, a former marine, and she's taking
on Mitch McConnell now back in 2018 in the
midterms, she tried to defeat Republican congressman
Andy Barr.
Uh, that was in the Kentucky Sixth district.
It didn't work.
Okay?
She certainly is a more moderate Democrat
than Bernie Sanders, right?
But this is Kentucky.
She's a right on way more issues than Mitch
McConnell is right on.
And this is a really big opportunity.
Now, I also want to be realistic.
I don't want to be negative, but this is an
uphill battle.
Knocking off an incumbent Republican senator
in a red state is tough in general, especially
when a president of the same party is up for
reelection as is the case in 2020.
Uh, but it is not impossible.
And even if Amy McGrath ultimately doesn't
win, she may be able to seriously damaged
Mitch McConnell in the process and more importantly,
she might be able to force the National Republican
Party to pour money into keeping Mitch McConnell's
seat, uh, which is money that then will not
go to other candidates and other seats, which
is a really good thing no matter what.
Now, there are some factors working against
Mitch McConnell and in Amy McGrath's favor.
Number one, Trump is not popular and McConnell
is certainly a Trump associated senator in
many ways.
Number two, McConnell is not actually that
popular.
McConnell's net approval is minus 13, meaning
13 percentage points of the population more
disapprove rather than approve of the job.
McConnell is doing and understand that Kentucky
is a very red state.
Kentucky Leans Towards Republicans by plus
23 and McConnell is minus 13.
Okay.
That's a minus 36 what's called popularity
above replacement Senator Score.
Uh, now all of this considered the unfortunate
truth is that a lot of those Republicans in
Kentucky who disapprove of Mitch McConnell
just want a different republican.
They don't want a Democrat, and they would
still choose McConnell over a democrat.
And we have only to look at Alabama to understand
how this works.
In December of 2017 there was a special election
in Alabama where serial accused sex assault
or Roy Moore almost won against Doug Jones
and more lost not because Republican said,
hey, let's vote for Doug Jones.
Doug Jones won and Roy Moore lost because
some Republicans just stayed home.
And remember more, almost did when Moore received
48.3% of the vote in that special election
in Alabama, the overwhelming majority of all
Republican voters who did choose to vote in
that election.
So let's see what happens.
It would be a massive victory to remove Mitch
McConnell.
It would be good for Amy McGrath.
Even if she's not the progressive.
I'd like it would be good for Amy McGrath
to replace Mitch McConnell.
And we've got to understand this as Kentucky.
It's not Massachusetts.
It's not Vermont.
It's not California.
Uh, so let's see what we can do to help Amy
McGrath in this election.
We'll talk about her more upcoming.